We're actually going to do some programming, and we're going to add a feature to ASCII Chan.
If you don't remember ASCII Chan is, we started using that in Unit 3, I believe.
It looks something like this.
We just have two inputs on a simple form, and we can insert in some ASCII art into the box here.
Then when we submit it, we see our art here on our page,
if we were to reload this page, we would show the 10 most recent pieces of artwork submitted.
Obviously, this site is going to be a big deal--a big social community.
I'd like to add some features to it.
What I'd like to do is to draw over here a map that shows on the map
where the most recent submissions came from,
so that when you come to ASCHII Chan you can see what a global community it is.
We have to do a couple things. Let's talk about them.
One thing we're going to need to do is figure out where the user submitting is from.
We're going to need some sort of service to convert the request IP into coordinates.
For this we'll be using a service I just found called "hostip.info," which is a handy little website.
I'll show you right now. I found this by googling.
Basically, you go to hostip.info and for any IP address, they will tell you where it's located.
They also have an API that has very simple documentation.
Basically, if we go to api.hostip.info and include the IP address in a get parameter,
they'll give us some XML with location data, and I'll show you what that looks like.
For IP--their example IP--we get all this information,
including city, country, country abbreviation, and what we're really after--some coordinates.
Here we've got the longitude and latitude.
This will be a really handle service that we'll be using.
We also want to draw a map, and for this we'll be using Google Maps.
Google Maps has a really handy service called "static maps,"
which is where we can basically make a URL that draws a make with markers on it.
I'll show you where the documentation for that lives.
That is here. It's called the Static Maps API version 2.
If we just scroll down here to a quick example, we can see the type of thing we can build.
Given this URL, it would load this image.
If we were to just copy this URL here and load it in a new tab,
we would get that image with the markers,
and these markers are all defined in the URL itself.
That's going to be a pretty cool, handy service.
What I want is a map just like this, and I want it to appear right here,
and I want it to have the location of the most recent submissions.